Scot is next in Spartanburg South
Carolina hey Scott how are you good
afternoon how are you they better than I
deserve sir how can I help
well I recently became debt-free about
two months ago back in October working
on my steps four and six excellent
and I'm an over-the-road truck driver
now my choice and I'm looking at paying
cash for a house in three to four years
but my question is during this three to
four years that I'm not needing a home
some of the funds as I build them up
would it be wise to purchase some homes
to do a little bit of renovation and
flip these houses to help build that up
quicker you paying cash for him I would
okay if you pay if you're flipping and
paying cash for the flip I'm fine with
that but don't know dad right yeah and I
don't want rental property until after
I'm decided to come off the road yeah
but here's the thing when you're
flipping a house there's two sides to
the equation and it sounds really simple
and really obvious but the way you make
money flipping houses is at the Buy and
at the sale the buy is you get a great
deal or you don't buy it I mean you got
to steal it or you don't buy it cuz
you're gonna make any spread on it I
mean you got to make a ton you gotta
have a lot of room to flip a house and
make money it's not as easy as everybody
thinks it is but they make it out to
sound on these weekend real estate deals
right yeah I've got my own 1,500 pieces
of property in my life and I'm flipped a
bunch of them so you really have to buy
it cheap and then here's the thing you
can't get desperate and give it away on
the sale and if you don't have any debt
there's two things that that does
there's something about paying cash for
a property that makes you more careful
so it'll help you on the Buy and you
don't have anything pushing you like
payments and some banker in your ear
causing you to sell it before and so you
can hold out for the best possible price
I very seldom sell a piece of real
estate these days but if I do I get the
top
possible market value for it or I don't
get rid of it I don't have any reason to
sell it you know it's it's the only
reason I would sell it as the the
offering price is ridiculously good and
that you got to be in that position to
make the flip work so when you're paying
cash it gives you the patience at the
sale and the care and carefulness on the
you know getting a great buy at the buy
and then that's your thing so just be
very careful learn learn learn learn
learn learn really do a detailed
construction estimates on the on the
renovation that you've got to do people
lose their butts on that to they don't
rise how much trouble they're getting
into how much of a price I mean how much
it's gonna cost to renovate it really do
detail to instruments on that be very
careful with that take your time and
then I don't care how cheap you think
you bought it it probably wasn't cheap
enough number one mistake people make
flipping out so they pay too much when
they buy them number 2 mistake they
borrow money so they get in a pinch and
have to sell them too cheap and that
does away with all your margin right
there this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Music]